[Music]
all right what's up mkbhd here welcome
back to dope tech and yes this is an
xbox series s fully portable in the
shape of a laptop with a display on it
and everything this is sent to me by the
creators of the x screen and for a
certain group of people
this is really cool so obviously
handheld gaming is having a bit of a
moment right now i am also currently
testing this little guy called the valve
steam deck you might have heard about it
uh leave a thumbs up if you're excited
for that video but this thing well this
is exactly what it looks like it's
called the x screen for xbox series s
and it basically turns the console into
a laptop form factor for you hardcore
gamers that want to play xbox games but
not just on the couch so basically all
you have to do is plug it in by
connecting this piece to the xbox like a
puzzle piece it has a usb plug and an
hdmi plug in the back and you plug them
in to line the whole thing up and then
there's two bonus little thumb screws
one on either side to help hold
everything in place and then you use
literally the original cable that came
with the xbox and then boom the whole
thing can light up just like this the
screen turns on
and you're gaming on the go now this
screen it's not the highest end screen
in the world on paper like the numbers
it's an 11.6 inch diagonal screen and
it's 1080p it's an ips at 60 hertz right
but it matches the size of the xbox
obviously to achieve this form factor
and then if you think about it 1080p
right so that the screen you might be
already gaming on for a console like
this is 1080p but this is obviously way
smaller so it's actually significantly
sharper the higher pixel density and so
you can sit much closer to it like i am
here and so it's really just about
convenience to match the size of the
xbox it's got the stereo speakers up top
it also has an optional stand mode to
help you get a better angle and it's got
a crosshair mode to help you better aim
and shooter games if you're into that
you basically just have to plug it in
and light it up and it starts gaming so
yeah you know it's not a 4k or 120 hertz
screen or anything like that but i
wasn't really expecting that much from
something that plugs directly into an
xbox and you know what it still does
have this nice matte finish which makes
it easy to see in a variety of lighting
situations it might face the audio gets
surprisingly loud honestly it's easy to
have a lot of fun playing this almost
anywhere that you could fit a normal or
super thick gaming laptop well except
for the fact that you do pretty much
always need to be plugged in i did see a
video on the creators youtube channel
where they have this massive 99 watt
hour battery and so you could in theory
bring it and the battery on a flight you
know get that seat back tray table going
but it lasts about 40 minutes so if you
have the seat on a plane with no outlet
this isn't exactly great but overall you
know aside from the rear usb and
ethernet ports being blocked and the
white color not quite exactly matching
up the same as the xbox plastic but
being really close uh this thing is
really well built and it's 250 bucks for
the whole kit so it's on kickstarter
right now that's basically the same
price as the xbox series s is going for
it's a little bit pricey but i'll say if
you have the outlet in the back of your
car and you want to play xbox games on
the go like this is yeah this is the
best way to actually do that until maybe
of course tesla finally ships that
gaming feature they've been promising
for so long so overall i'm gonna give
this seven out of ten if it's actually
shipping and people are playing xbox
games on the go
that's pretty dope all right these might
be the strangest but coolest earbuds
design i've ever seen these are called
sony link buds they're brand new you
might have seen me tweet about them the
other day and right away you can tell
they're
pretty different from normal earbuds
you're saying things correctly the
earbud
is a circle the part that actually goes
into your ear
is a circle
i'll explain so a lot of the headphones
we use right now have active noise
cancellation but then a separate feature
that they started adding more and more
often which is some sort of transparency
mode so it uses the microphones around
the earbud to pump in sound from the
outside so you can walk around on the
streets and still hear the cars around
you or hear when your bus or train stop
gets called so these well these are
designed so you can always hear your
environment around you even when you're
wearing them so they have an 11
millimeter circular driver and a hole in
the middle so when you put the earbuds
in without playing any music you can
still hear a lot of the outside world
around you then when you play music well
yeah it sounds like the headphones are
on with the transparency mode now i
found it's not actually as good as say
airpods pro because those microphones
are actually amplifying your environment
so with these you know if there's music
playing you still hear a little bit of
what's around you but you can actually
drown it out if you turn the volume up
loud enough but i really have been
impressed with how well these actually
work i mean clearly the physics makes
sense
there's a hole through it but yeah now
you're letting in constantly a
non-adjustable amount of sound from the
outside world so it's great for
listening to music while cars are around
you or on public transportation so you
can still hear when your bus stop gets
hauled or something like that it's
consistent so then the idea with these
is even when you're done using them done
listening to music or taking a phone
call or whatever it is you're doing you
can just leave them in your ears because
you'll have transparency mode you'll
have the ability to hear what's going on
around you all the time even when the
earbuds are in and it doesn't take
extra battery power to do that
so now you're just having a normal
conversation now the other thing you may
have noticed is these earbuds are pretty
tiny like the buds themselves are very
small and the recycled plastic case they
fit in as a result is also very
pocketable but the downside is that
there's no space on the buds themselves
for media controls anywhere but that's
where the second crazy feature comes
into play you can adjust volume
by tapping the skin around your ears
so the sony connect app lets you program
a double tap or a triple tap of your own
skull on the right or left hand side and
his earbuds are sensitive enough of
their own position that you can map a
double tap on the right hand side to be
volume a double tap on the left hand
side could be
skipping tracks or even opening google
assistant or accepting a phone call it's
awesome overall as crazy as these are
they are surprisingly usable they're 179
bucks um small case no wireless charging
but it does have usb type-c and it gives
you a five-hour total battery life with
these
sound quality is solid if anything it's
lacking a little bit of bass because
it's not getting into your ear like
normal earbuds might but yeah if you can
get the touch controls to work well
they're finicky sometimes but you got to
tap like
right up next to your ear
they're pretty cool i'm gonna give these
an eight out of ten okay this next
product i know is absolutely not meant
for me but i can still respect it anyway
this is a super high-end gaming
tablet and i just need you to know that
this is real and this is something that
actually exists so this is the asus rog
flow z13 this thing has an up to 14 core
intel core i9 processor a geforce rtx
3050 ti graphics card a 1080p 120 hertz
display or a 4k 60 hertz option
up to one terabyte of m.2 ssd storage
and a vapor chamber cooling solution on
the back
so yes it's a full-fledged gaming
computer running windows you can think
of it kind of like a surface pro but
just way more gaming focused now i can't
imagine battery life will be killer on
something like this most of the time but
hey gaming laptops don't typically have
amazing battery life either so that's
not a huge surprise
i'm just i'm really into this design
though the aesthetics of how they
managed to shove all that power into a
tablet sized package it's got some
thickness to it of course and it's
definitely not lightweight
but you know it's a reasonable layout
there's a power button and volume
rockers on the right side along with a
combo microphone headphone jack and a
speaker at the bottom and then there's a
single usb type-c thunderbolt port on
the left side along with this labeled
xgm port which is going to let you plug
in different external gpus there's pins
and magnets at the bottom for docking a
keyboard accessory just like the surface
and there's no ports up top but just
heat dissipation just heat sinks heat
radiating out the top and look at that
leds
pcb and the angular cutout in the
kickstand that is a really nice touch
and i'm not just saying that because
it's red and black although that
certainly helps but they've made as many
clever incisions for ventilation and
angular gamer aesthetic as possible and
they seem to have gotten away with it
now the 3050 ti isn't the highest in
graphics card in the world i get that if
you want to play the witcher 3 or
cyberpunk or something like that on high
settings you're going to need more power
probably something in a laptop form
factor but that's why this thing can
plug into those external gpu attachments
the same stuff that the rog flow thin
and light laptop could plug into because
this is meant to actually game on you
should definitely watch dave 2d's full
video on it he gets 120 fps on this
tablet in overwatch it's a tablet it's
hilarious i'll link it below so the
thing is a tablet when you want it to be
but can plug into this rog xg mobile
graphics dock which gives you up to an
rtx 3080. basically you're buying a
gaming laptop in two parts if that makes
sense but i keep coming back to
everything i like about just the back of
this tablet the subtle texture of the
metal the rock solid stand with this
window cut out and under the kickstand
there's a bunch of outlines giving you a
peek at what's inside so the m.2 ssd the
battery and of course an opening to a
micro sd card slot there's also a set of
coordinates on the back which if you
google them appears to direct you to
asus's headquarters in taiwan best part
though
they still included
the camera on the back because somewhere
out there there's somebody who would
spend a bunch of money
there isn't even a price for this thing
yet but a bunch of money probably on a
super high-end gaming
tablet but still would take pictures
with it
anyway i'm giving this thing like a 9
out of 10 just for the aesthetic i'm a
huge fan but then last thing i want to
mention this usbc power cable with the
display readout on the end has been
awesome so basically ever since i showed
it in my everyday carry video i've been
carrying it and it's low key just like
nerdy fun to just be able to plug in and
see exactly what sort of wattage you're
getting from your charger on any device
you know we always talk about peak
charging versus actual overall average
charging rates this is so obviously
unnecessary and overkill but being able
to see exactly what type of power you're
drawing at any given moment maybe it's
30 watts maybe it's 22 maybe it's your
laptop you're pulling over 100 from low
battery i don't know it's just so
entertaining now the thing about this
every time i link it anywhere it sells
out so i'm trying to do my best to keep
an updated link in the description
for wherever i can find it in stock i'll
do that again with this video but no
promises if you want this you'll
probably have to act pretty fast good
luck okay really truly last but not
least as a reward for making it this far
into the video
giveaway time what better way to cap it
off so i'm teaming up with aaron from mr
who's the boss who just recently hit 10
million subscribers huge shout out to
him and congrats it's incredible
milestone
and we're also going to be teaming up
with dbrand the logistics kings in tech
that make this all possible and why not
just do a massive giveaway to celebrate
it all and by massive giveaway i mean
possibly the biggest tech giveaway of
all time so up for grabs is 10 iphone 13
pro maxes all with matte black dbrand
skins applied
10
samsung galaxy s22 ultras all with the
new atomic grip case which is super nice
but then there's way more
20 playstation 5s with d brands dark
plates don't ask me how we got these 30
of the new oled nintendo switch
50 dbrand grip cases made for whatever
phone you've got right now
80 pairs of the latest airpods 3 all
dbranded and 100 t-shirts but not just
any t-shirts 50 limited edition of a new
design from aaron and 50 of the iconic
histogram shirt from myself all you have
to do to enter is hit the link in the
description
tons of chances to win and it's super
easy to hit the link and come back and
just to check on the progress of who's
been winning what as the giveaway goes
on now as a bonus aaron's idea was that
for every single one of you that enters
he'd be donating two cents to a charity
called solar aid which gives
solar-powered lights to families in need
who would otherwise have to burn
dangerous fuels and risk fires so this
is a great cause and for me it was kind
of a no-brainer that i would match that
so between the two of our channels two
cents from him and two cents from me for
every single one of you that enters this
giveaway
it's a pretty positive impact we're able
to make how about that tech giveaway
that actually has a little bit of a
positive impact on the planet so get
entered below good luck
thanks for watching dope tech and i'll
catch you guys the next one
peace
[Music]